all right
put simply training attendance is one of
the single most important aspects of
your training that you're probably not
putting enough emphasis on
having strong attenders not only protect
against injury that only helps you to
combat and reduce pain that you might be
experiencing can also help you to unlock
your true athleticism because tenders
are capable of far greater force output
than is muscle if you're only training
your muscle you're leaving a huge amount
of performance on the table whether
you're an athlete whether you're a
lifter whether you're just a physical
culturist
my previous video on tendon training is
one of my most successful however that
video is also four years old now while
it mostly holds up I've learned an awful
lot since then through study through
personal experience and through
conversations I've had with some truly
amazing experts in their fields
and with tendon training being so
incredibly important I felt it was
crucial to share them with you it was
time for a Redux
so welcome to my new comprehensive guide
to detention training for 2023 and
Beyond
if I'm gonna do this right though if I'm
gonna make this a truly comprehensive
guide to tendon training then I need to
speak to a true expert and I happen to
know just the guy
so why is training the tenants so
important well simply put muscle doesn't
work in a vacuum whenever you place the
muscle under strain you're also placing
the tendons under strain it helps to
think not just in terms of muscles but
in terms of mtus or muscle tendon units
in fact it makes even more sense to
think about muscles in the context of
the broader system how they relate to
other muscles in the body and the rest
of your connective tissue like the
fascia if you want to get the maximum
performance then you need to be training
in specific ways to strengthen this
connective tissue because simply curling
weights isn't going to do it lifting
weights will improve your tendon
strength to a degree but it's very
limited compared with specifically
targeting those things and because so
few people actively train their tendons
this is actually a kind of untapped well
it's kind of a frontier of performance
that you can tap into and then
outperform your peers or competitors
there's a great video from Keegan Smith
the 80g coach on this topic he discusses
how someone like Stefan Holm is able to
generate incredible power despite not
having big bulky strong legs and he does
this by using his tendon Stephen Hawking
legitimately leap over your head
probably like a ninja another example he
uses are break dancers who can do these
incredible things that once again aren't
possible because of their muscle
strength but rather because of their
tendon strength but for a lot of people
this is a moot point they're nowhere
near the point where they're able to
perform breakdancing moves and instead
they just want to focus on moving
healthily and pain-free a lot of joint
complaints come down to problems with
tendons and because we aren't
stimulating the tendons properly through
our daily lives or through our training
our muscles tend to outpace the tendons
and this can lead to injury and many
people think this is a life sentence
they think they're bad knee or their bad
back is something that they simply can't
reverse however we've seen plenty of
examples that demonstrate this isn't the
case you can train and heal your tendons
if you go about it in the right way and
this might be the secret to longevity
and I'm doing a lot of that damage and
starting to regain normal healthy
movement in this video I was fortunate
enough to be joined by a true expert and
Trailblazer in this field then Patrick
AKA knees over toes guy so it's actually
finding those points of of pressure
which is where we can potentially
stimulate the tendon to grow
first we need to build that base of
strength and resilience as I've
discussed many times before a new lifter
will start to see structural changes to
their muscle in as little as eight days
conversely it typically takes around two
months for the same thing to occur in
the tendons this is largely due to lower
blood supply to the tendons as compared
with the muscles the lack of blood
vessels that travel through the tendons
is partly what makes them so strong
however it also makes them much slower
to heal and grow so if you're new to
training and you start lifting very
heavy weights there's a high chance you
may injure a tendon and this is
especially true if you're training using
traditional lifts that utilize a short
range of motion and largely don't Target
the tendons at all my recommendation
then has always been to promote blood
flow to the muscles and tendons and two
great ways to accomplish this are
through high volume training and high
frequency training using lighter weights
and varied calisthenics movements by
moving often in a wide variety of ways
we keep blood flowing to the tendons and
keep them healthy this is one reason
that children are so Supple and
resistant to tendon injuries and muscle
tears so I'm alone away from Ben's level
of knee strength and performance but
they are pretty strong and resilient and
I'm able to do things that I know makes
some people cringe like [ __ ] squats or
bunny Hops and the reason I think for
this is partly just that I'm constantly
training them throughout the day I like
to use what I call incidental training
as you guys know so nearly every time I
kneel down which you do a lot when
you've got kids I do it like this
kneeling and then when I want to stand
up I go like this in the gym using large
sets of light reps with continuous time
under tension sets of fast push-ups
curls or leg extensions for example
should cause the blood to travel to the
muscles and pool there because the
muscle is being constantly contracted it
doesn't have a chance to escape acting
like a form of occlusion or AKA Blood
Flow Restriction Training we see this
when people type tourniquets over their
muscles over time this can lead to
permanently enhanced blood supply thanks
to a phenomenon called angiogenesis the
birth of new blood vessels we know that
a vascularity a lack of blood supply is
associated with degenerative tendon
disease and the increased blood supply
triggered by the release of vascular
endothelial growth factor v e g f is a
critical part of the healing process and
it has also been shown that Blood Flow
Restriction Training can enhance vegf
production versus regular training along
with General angiogenic gene expression
in other words pump training builds
blood vessels and this is very logical
continuous time and attention and a cool
training play significant Demand on the
tendon blood supply the body responds by
increasing that blood supply following
such training the body now has greater
blood flow to the affected region
enabling more rapid recovery and lower
incidence of injury then you'll be ready
for the next level of tendon training to
unlock crazy performance gains once you
know that your tendons could withstand
some punishment you can begin to train
them directly lifting heavy weights will
always place the tenders under Force
however the amount of force will always
be limited as the muscles act like a
kind of buffer and because the tendons
can handle greater force than the
muscles weight training alone is not
enough to tap into their maximum
potential at least not traditional
weight training that uses shorter ranges
of motion this is where we have to get
creative in the past I've discussed
using techniques such as heavy partials
moves like rack pulls the place the
tendons and the greater load than you
normally could heavy negatives can work
in the same manner letting you support
more weight than you can lift but there
may be a much more efficient way to
Target the tendons and this is where
needs ever toes guy really comes into
his own so no another option is to use
weighted stretching weighted stretching
uses lighter weight but takes you
through a much greater range of motion
than does regular training and because
the muscle reaches its maximum length
this means much more force is going to
be transferred to the tendon weighted
stretching can increase range of motion
and Mobility it can help you to generate
strength from a stretched position such
as the bottom of a squat for a far more
massive jump height and it can make you
incredibly resilient against injury and
this is where the narrative around
training has traditionally been all
wrong for decades now the advice has
been to avoid any movements that play
strain on the tendons and the most
famous example of course is letting the
knees pass the taste when squatting the
logic was that because letting the knees
pass the toes places pressure on the
tendon it increases the risk of injury
did you know that doing bicep curls puts
pressure on your biceps so we should
probably stop doing them right in case
we hurt our biceps
and once we're at it maybe we should
just stop moving entirely I think
that'll probably be safer for everybody
that it was a study in 1978 that scared
everyone away from these over toes yeah
only for it to be found later
that training the over toe returns
athlete to sport faster builds the
tendon yeah only to only to still find
that even a full range of motion squat
contrary to popular concern actually
makes you less likely to have a knee
injury strengthens your lower body no
one has done as much to Champion the
importance of tendon training as Ben and
his team through his various programs
he's helped countless people to restore
their needs and develop amazing
aestheticism but his Concepts don't just
apply to the knees the same ideas can be
applied to the lats the shoulders the
elbows the back the hips you name it Ben
believes in training every angle at
every range Ben and the athletic truth
group have also done the most to codify
this type of training utilizing a
combination of what they call short
range and long-range movements to
effectively Target the tendons at all
positions in short range movements this
is something like a pulse squat or a
backwards sled pull you utilize High
repetitions and lighter weights to get
the blood flowing to the tendons just as
we discussed earlier
so short-range training is particularly
advantageous to getting a lot of
circulation and a lot of blood flow then
something like dragging a sled backward
for 10 minutes straight has quite
literally got thousands of people off
painkillers for the knee but that is not
how you bulletproof your knees it is it
is building to the fullest range the
fullest quote unquote pressure that you
can take a joint
that is actually how you make it more
resilient so it's understanding that any
exercise is on a scale of range of
motion doing a reverse step up that's
another one that you can scale to really
really easy levels
so compared to just don't let your knee
over your toe versus
finding a short range of motion with the
knee over the toe building up strength
yeah now you start to find that some of
those longer range exercises all of a
sudden don't hurt as much these
movements actually minimize the load on
the tendons and can be used to move
those areas safely while also building
strength annual Drive in preparation for
what comes next
but long range movements are the real
secret Source these act like those
weighted stretches placing the tendons
under greater load and can otherwise be
accomplished these include things like
the atg split squat like they seated
good morning and anything else that puts
you in that real stretch position whilst
under load and while these movements
might look a bit scary they should be
treated like any other Advanced movement
build up to them don't dive straight in
don't train through pain listen to your
body take your time and these are not
only safe but crucially important for
long-term health and performance
foreign
so this can be a little bit tricky to
visualize so I thought I'd create a
little bit of a learning Aid and I made
this basically what this is is it's two
pieces of elastic tied to a piece of
string and here the elastic is meant to
represent the tendons and the string is
supposed to represent the muscle and
obviously the tendons are actually
harder than the muscles so in that sense
this doesn't quite make sense but what
we're going to be doing is keeping slack
in the string and that's supposed to
represent the the muscle in a shortened
State and then when it lengthens it goes
straight like that if you use these
extrema ranges of motion if you use a
long range movement then suddenly the
muscle can stretching it further and now
that force is being transferred
to the tendons on either end like why
like what I dreaded as my favorite
exercise the ask to grasp split Squat
and I use to show how simple it is
um
I use a rubber wedge someone can get an
industrial sized doorstop so that's what
I use so this is not some fancy
invention it's just bigger it's just a
bigger door
yeah um so this this elevates the heel
so the ball of the foot is down
by assisting yourself you can get just
about anyone into this because we're
talking about uh less than the amount of
strength needed to go down the stairs
you're turning going down the stairs and
going back up the stairs backward you're
turning that into a precisely measurable
strength exercise done for a higher
number of repetitions over time that's
like your foundational short range knee
exercise now imagine you have a twin one
of them avoids knees over toes the other
one builds up strength in that short
range you now have more muscle tissue
you have more tendon tissue you're
getting more circulation to heal old
injuries now when you start to progress
into a full range of motion split squat
there's less chance of pain there's more
strength there and then there's still
another range though all right there's
still one more range which is outer
range so yeah so something like a [ __ ]
squat that the most bulletproof of the
bulletproof of knees can do that's
really getting into an outer range it's
not just a long range like when you do a
full range of motion squad or split
squat you hit a resting Point like it
stops yeah it's a long range it stops
but when you do a [ __ ] squat it doesn't
really stop it actually is almost like
you're at like the limit of like stretch
that can occur that's an outer range and
there are other ways to overload the
tendons too for example plyometric or
shock training can be a powerful tool
for example if you land from a box jump
of 42 inches you'll be absorbing a shock
equal to roughly three to four times
your body weight this is far more than
most people can Squat and it's not the
muscle that handles this Force it's the
tendons so what's key here is that the
amortization phase of the movement the
little pores at the bottom where the
direction is reversed this is where you
absorb that energy and return it even
just loading a heavy weight onto your
back and bouncing at the bottom of a
squat can create increased momentary
Force to challenge the tendons another
option is isometric training this means
training without moving holding away in
position or pushing and pulling against
an immovable object in these cases
because the muscle is not lengthening or
shortening more force is once again
transferred to the tendons this makes
extreme isometrics a powerful tool for
training tendons and increasing blood
flow in perhaps an even more targeted
manner than the aforementioned pump
training an extreme isometric is just a
normal yielding isometric held for a
really long period of time like upwards
of several minutes sometimes a great
example would be something like the
horse dance which is perfect for
training the tendons indeed a large
focus of Shaolin training was originally
to strengthen the sinew quasi isometrics
meanwhile or extremely slow reps of
challenging movements can also be
effective to this end meanwhile you can
use overcoming isometrics we push or
pull against a completely immovable
Force for around 6 seconds to build
significantly greater tendon strength or
ballistic isometrics where you perform
isometrics but with explosive intent and
if you want to see a visceral example of
how this can lead to tendon Remodeling
and growth just look at the hands of any
rock climber that has been training for
a few years they'll typically have huge
hands and thick fingers as a result of
hanging from the fingers stretching them
exploding from them and using them on a
nearly daily basis
it's also really important that you
support this by likewise putting the
effort in outside of the gym with the
right lifestyle and with the right diet
and nutrition and supplementation of
course you want to cover the basics
sleep can go an awfully a long way
likewise you want to avoid things like
smoking studies show that smoking can
impair tendon healing and then you want
to read a balanced and nutritious diet
including lots of protein lots of
minerals and in particular lots of
collagen there are plenty of studies now
demonstrating collagen's usefulness in
not only restoring normal Health to
tendons and encouraging repair and
recovery even turning back the clock but
also how it can actually improve
athleticism perhaps improving jump
height and running speed I'm not going
to go into this in much more detail
because it's not my area of interest but
suffice to say that if like I say you're
putting in the work in the gym you need
to make sure you're eating right
recovering right and just treating your
body well outside of the gym as well so
there you go guys that was a pretty much
comprehensive introduction to tendon
training there is definitely more to say
on this topic it's a massive topic just
like muscle for example I'd love to go
into detail in future about how tendons
make you move more efficiently by
allowing you to return energy when
walking for example so that you hardly
need to contract your muscles at all I'd
like to talk about the relationship
between flexibility and tendon stiffness
for athleticism I'd like to talk about
the relationship between tendons and
fascia these are topics I'll likely be
covering in the coming months so if that
sounds interesting then please subscribe
I'd like to take this moment to say a
massive thank you to Ben Patrick needs
ever toes guy for appearing in this
video and being so generous with his
time I've been a massive fan of Benz for
an awfully long time I constantly
reference his moves and ideas in these
videos so it was only a matter of time
before I got him on the channel if you
have any knee pain or any other joint
pain then I highly recommend checking
out his stuff I'll leave links to that
in description down below I will be
sharing the full conversation with him
in the coming days so stay tuned for
that as well alternatively if you're
looking for a training program that
covers a broad spectrum of different
training Styles and combines them in one
place combining things like kettlebell
training weightlifting calisthenics all
into a single program that does also
include a lot of weighted stretches and
Mobility work then check out my ebook
and training program super functional
training 2.0 the protein performance
system a huge thank you as well to Paul
and Louise for not only letting me film
at their gym first for fitness and Vista
which is fantastic and you should check
it out if you're local but also to Paul
for demonstrating some movements they
even let me bring my massive player box
and take up loads of space that way and
a massive thank you to Anytime Fitness
in Vista for also letting me film there
I think that's all the thanks out of the
way oh yeah thanks to you guys so much
for watching this one and I'll catch you
next time
bye for now